est-ce que vous croyez au diable oui
bien sûr quand je vous vois
vous êtes croyant donc je vais vous
faire une interview croyante
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pêché mon père j'ai bougé pendant
notre
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous croyez au diable oui
bien sûr quand je vous vois
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que tu as eu un rire ça
est-ce que vous croyez que la France va
gagner l'Eurovision cette année
oui
est-ce que vous croyez aux
extraterrestres non aux anges oui ça
existe les anges oui au moins
esthétiquement et poétiquement et
artistiquement et pourquoi pas
surnaturellement vrai les anges gardiens
il y a un ange que je prie toujours
avant de venir à l'émission de
télévision c'est l'ange des vanités tu
dis souffle moi sur la gueule pour que
je me prenne pas trop au sérieux que je
ne me gonfle pas de vanité
il y en a des anges gardiens ou pas
de sexe bien sûr
qu'il y a des plaisirs plus grands que
ceux du sac
quand tu seras roi il aura besoin vous
aurez besoin d'avoir quelqu'un
tu vois très bien tu vois très bien
qu'on fait ça auprès d'un en plus il a
rien dit sur tous les hommes politiques
je crois
tu l'inviteras après il y a rien non non
c'est clair il y a Carlos de Bourbon qui
me demande aussi que tu vois
en même temps il s'en fout il fait 700
personnes tous les soirs Philippe Tesson
dit que c'est un génie qu'est-ce que je
lui dise moi il continue est-ce que vous
croyez à l'efficacité des crèmes
anti-rides on se m’intéresse pas du tout
non
c'est le questionnaire
vous croyez à la réincarnation à la
réincarnation non je crois la
résurrection ce qui est très différent
expliquez-nous alors
réincarnation c'est s'imaginer que
lorsqu'on a été langouste ou Amar et
qu'on a péché on va devenir crapaud et
qu'on va descendre de plus en plus bas
et qu'au contraire quand on a été bien
on va devenir baleine et ensuite colibri
alors que la résurrection c'est lorsque
vous croyez il y a un raciste animalier
terrible pourquoi colibri c'est mieux
que baleine
et la résurrection c'est très différent
c'est de croire qu'après la mort l'amour
est plus fort que la vie et que la
création est tellement belle qu'elle
renaîtra avec nous avec des corps mais
avec des plaisirs infiniment supérieur à
celui du sexe la région des corps
bien je ne méprise pas le sexe ah non
mais j'espère bien dis donc est-ce que
vous croyez que Chirac sera réélu en
j'espère qu'il y aura un groupe qui se
formera qui s'appellera tout sauf Chirac
un groupe de rock
qui va se présenter
il a fait une très belle biographie du
roi Henri IV bien entendu l'Empire il a
des racines quel charisme en plus
[Applaudissements]
chrétiens quand même c'est plus votre
truc quoi mais je crois que c'est à ce
point là quand même
bien est-ce que vous croyez à la mort
d'Elvis non
il y a 20 % les Américains qui pensent
comme vous mon père est-ce que vous
croyez au sexe sans amour ah non c'est
le pire qui puisse arriver et est-ce que
vous croyez à l'amour sans sexe oui
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu